okay good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's planning committee meeting
my name is councilor Peter Richards and
I will be chairing this evening's
meeting some housekeeping if I made to
start with we're not expecting a fire
alarm doesn't mean one won't go off so
if it does go off if you could please
follow us to the car park
um opposite as we can check all your
names off and make sure everyone is
safely out the building before you go uh
you'll make your way home uh mobile
phones if you could please turn them off
at the very least to silence I
appreciate some people may need to use
them I don't mind that provider doesn't
disturb the flow of this meeting so at
the silence at the very least but off
would be preferable the meeting itself
is a meeting in public it is not a
public meeting so only those people have
registered to speak will be permitted to
do so at the appropriate time I'll call
you forward to one of the three chairs
in front of us
um give you a lot of time if you press
the button in the middle of the
microphone it should go red and then
you'll be able to speak and when you're
done if you could stay seated for
questions that would be very helpful as
well we are of course being live
streamed and recorded for later viewing
on YouTube should you wish to relive
this wonderful moment
um some introductions uh to our panel so
um to my far right we have Mason Nash
who is our committee Services
representative to my immediate rights we
have Sue Mullins who is our solicitor
and our planners are Joe Brook and Sarah
Flaherty and our planning manager of the
evening is Emily Napier Emily I believe
you have a statement to make
foreign
my role tonight is to provide impartial
advice to committee members and to
assist members in their decision taking
thank you very much right let's get into
the meeting proper apologies for absence
we have any apologies please
apologies chair from councilor Eden uh
Hendrick seraphin and councilor Parry
with councilor Harvey substituting and
Council Rock with councilor Adam
substituting
marvelous thank you very much and
Welcome to our substitutes
um disclose of it excuse me discloses of
Interest members do we have any
disclosures please Council Mills first
thanks Mr chairman yes uh on application
four on the agenda that's um two two
stroke zero one seven nine three stroke
if you will
um I'm the county councilor for for this
division but um I haven't spoken to
anybody at the parish council and
approaches with an open mind Mr chairman
so hopefully I can stay and uh on the
panel thank you and also uh on uh
application five on the agenda uh East
house Kendricks Barn Church Bank Benton
I did go on a site visits and met with
the applicants but I shall still
approach this one over my Mr chairman
thank you marvelous thank you very much
uh councilor Crump
thank you Mr chairman um I know the
agent uh for the first one
22000 51 stroke out I used to work with
him at a local District Council
um Notting him for a good while and
we've not had any conversation about
this uh
um application so I'll come into the
meeting with an open mind on that
I love it yeah lovely thank you very
much any others Curtis
thank you yes application 5
2201798 full Kendricks Barn I also made
a site visit and when I made the time
that I realized that I am actually or I
know the applicant in this instance
um we did some work together on media
interviews some seven or eight years ago
but I approach this with an open mind
okay lovely any others I'll make mine
now then so on same application
2201798 ful East house
um the applicant is known to me as a
friend of mine so I will make myself
scarce during that that item I'll remove
myself from the chair and cancel the
Kendall will very ably take over for me
for that item and item six uh
application reference
2201440 fulo welcome Farm in Smithfield
I'm the war member for I've made no
representations I've not spoken to
anyone about this uh and I'm here with
an open mind so I will come back and
stay on the committee for that item
marvelous okay
um we have no minutes to approve so
we'll move straight to our first
application which is application twenty
two zero zero zero five one out that is
land off long Marsden Road in welfare
upon Avon our presenting officer is Joe
Brook Joe over to you thank you uh let
me just set up the presentation
the site is located in the open
Countryside approximately 1.6 kilometers
from Wellford and 550 meters north of
long Marsden as indicated by the black
dot before you so to give some context
application Site Long Marsden to South
and Welford is just up there to the
north
the application seats outline consent
with all matter reserved for the
erection of a new industrial estate
comprising of commercial development for
use of Class E part G B2 and B8 on 1.82
hectares of area of land
once again I do have to highlight this
application is for outline only with all
matter reserved nonetheless as expressed
by the applicant the units would be of a
similar design and finish to the
adjacent Business site utilizing High
Bay industrial units with powder coated
aluminum windows and doors with a high
Bay sectional overhead door
the indicative layout Plan before you
shows a range of 21 units ranging from a
size of 111 square meters for to 445
square meters
I'll just leave this on for two seconds
so that members can get a good look at
the site you see in this is the
industrial sites itself which I will
show on the photos and go into more
detail
smaller units as proposed a few larger
units and the smaller units compromising
the site as well
so this is taken from Google Earth but
I've included it because it gives you a
real good context of the overall site so
this is the access into the site that's
already been laid
this is a site area so you see the
industrial unit to the surface of the
site which is the self storage unit and
if permitted this would be the outline
consent and the reserve matters stage
would be where the industrial units
would be developed
so this is the actual application site
now as you can see it's come a bit
larger overgrown so this is within the
area of the site looking onto the
industrial units
industrial units industrial units uh
sorry this wherever the industrial units
is that is you can see my car so that's
the access point coming into it
obviously this would all be removed
CC industrial units itself which is a
self storage units the application site
would be approximately there coming in
Behind These trees just there
now as part of the applications I set
out in the report it is also proposing a
public footpath so you can just see in
the distance the industrial unit now the
public footpath is proposed to go along
this side Verge all the way up Lincoln
long Marsden from this application here
that's the end of the presentation but I
will quickly slide back to the outline
so everyone is clear on I think so
that's the industrial site
and then up to North is the existing
Gypsy and traveler sites and then
obviously long Mars into South and
Wellford to North
in summary and I'll set on the office
report the application does not record a
development plan as the development
would result in the creation of a new
industrial estate on Greenfield land in
the open Countryside The Proposal is
considered not to call the police
stipulations as10 and cs-22 concerned
development you know consider or would
also does not meet the criteria policy
he-5 of the welfare non-avon
neighborhood development plan
if you do know on your update sheet
there are two updates one from character
Pemberton offering his support to the
application and also we did undertake an
assessment regarding gas lines which was
no objection but any future application
might require consultation and another
assessment
thank you
Joe thank you very much indeed um we
will call our first Speaker of the
evening who's councilor Jamie Hockaday
from welfare Parish Council
good evening
at Council today you have been here
before so I think you know the drill but
just to recap you'll have three minutes
I'll give you a 30 second warning before
your time is up and if you can stay
seated for questions afterwards
otherwise when you're ready the time is
yours I wouldn't I wouldn't like the 30
second uh no no I don't need that thank
you very much
um
so the application is supported by the
ward member Wellford on open Parish
Council long Marston Parish Council the
campaign for protection of rural England
and the County Council
policy he-5 of the name of a plan
requires the preservation of the beauty
of open Countryside
subject to landscape quality
considerations it supports reuse of
Brownfield sites and reuse for extension
of buildings this site is scruffy and
derelict surrounded by development The
Proposal will enhance the setting and
will also reuse a previously developed
site a landscape condition could provide
further enhancement
stated objective 4 of the neighborhood
plan encourages a range of community and
employment business Activities The
Proposal is therefore in accordance with
the neighborhood plan
The Village Welford on Abram has lost
3.7 hectares of employment land to
housing long Marston Airfield has also
been lost to 3 000 homes this proposal
is for 1.82 hectares so will only
replace 50 percent of what has been lost
in the village
objective 13 of the core strategy
requires a sustainable balance between
employment growth and housing provision
be maintained
SDC has recently announced it has a
10-year land housing Supply and it has
exceeded 1 000 housing completions
consistently for the last six years
SDC is not providing an adequate supply
of land to meet the current and growing
need of employment space an initial call
for employment sites was made in May and
June this year
the scheme is in compliance with the
mppf paragraph 85 recognizes rural
employment can be located Beyond these
little existing settlement boundaries
which are not served well by public
transport this land has been previously
developed and is well related to the
settlement the application is
sustainable because it's not Reliant
solely on the motor car people can walk
a bus stop is proposed the site is also
in close proximity to Stratford Greenway
providing a safe cycle route
The Proposal will also provide a range
of economic benefits
this application had been considered to
be acceptable by the case officer the
council's legal department had indeed
been instructed to prepare a draft to
section 106 agreement for this site to
support a delegated approval
there is compelling planning evidence to
support this application whether a
committee or a appeal and I would urge
you to support
thank you very much
thank you very much indeed well within
your time members do we have any
questions for our counselor please
no I have one you suggested this site
has already been developed it didn't
look very developed to me can you give
me some bit more information for that
please okay so yes the site has a
history of being a nursery
um and that's um there is evidence of
former nurseries buildings still on the
site and hard standings and footings we
also have the situation
um whereby
this Council has considered that this
site to be a Brownfield site in the
officers report he gives a very helpful
uh chronology of various planning
applications planning our operations
1402 954 full which is mentioned in the
report
that in its um summary to committee
talks about the site being a Brownfield
site
there is also another planning
application which is not mentioned in
the committee report which is 10
um
01796
which
stated that the proposal at the time
which was for Caravans that this would
be a loss of an employment site
um and we've also got history in Welford
um where a site known as Orchard
nurseries which was a nursery site
application reference
1901751 full was deemed to be a
Brownfield site
um
as well
okay lovely thank you very much cancer
Curtis did I see your hand go up thank
you
um just very briefly um you mentioned I
think that you said that previously this
application or at some point had been
acceptable to the officer but has there
been a change could you just give a
little more clarification on that please
okay so in speaking with the applicant
um the who was it there there is a
proposal as part of this application
that there'll be a section 106 agreement
which involves a footway connecting the
scheme to Long Marston 500 meters away
and a bus stop
and the applicant had been asked to fund
the council's legal costs and indeed the
applicant had made a payment to this
Council for two thousand pounds to cover
the legal costs associated with drafting
that section 106 agreement and that's
all been during the
um you know the period in which this
application has been considered
I think that's perhaps something we also
want to clarify with our officers later
on but that's a very helpful uh
um synopsis for me thank you Council
Crump did I see your hand go up
no I was just going to suggest that we
need to clarify that with offices okay
we'll do that later on thank you anyone
else have any questions
no council today thank you very much for
your time thank you
okay our next speaker on this item is Mr
Gary Stevens our agent
good evening Mr Stevens and welcome
so in the same way you'll have three
minutes uh do you want your 30 second
warning
yep so I'll give you a 30 second warning
uh stay season questions afterwards if
you would otherwise when you're ready if
you press the button in the middle the
floor is yours
thank you chair
um I'm speaking on behalf of the
applicant Mr Roy Foster who is the
landowner and wishes to bring this land
forward for business development
in your consideration of the application
this evening please can you take into
account the following points
some of you may recall an application
for business development on this site
was reported to Committee in January
2021
it was refused but the vote was split
and there are a number of material
considerations which now exist which
weigh in favor of Grant's permission
tonight
firstly technical concerns related to
flood risk have been resolved and there
is no objection from the flood Authority
secondly previous concerns related to
the inability of employees to walk or
cycle or catch a bus to the proposed
development have been addressed through
the commitment given by the applicant to
provide a footpath to Long Marston and
the bus stops outside the site which has
been agreed with the highway Authority
nursing of course at the proposed
footpath and bus stops would also serve
existing employees and residents who
live near to this site and therefore
represent a wider benefit
thirdly there is no clear and convincing
evidence of an acute shortage of
employment land and premises available
that isn't just our view that is the
conclusions of the recent research
undertaken for the council that is for
informing emerging planning policy
of course the current economic
circumstances that adds fuel to the need
to provide more opportunities for jobs
especially in this rapidly growing part
of the district
fourthly National planning policy has
changed government policy provides
support for economic growth of business
businesses in the rural area
recognizing that sites have to be found
Beyond existing settlements
whilst it is debatable whether the site
is a Brownfield side
what is certain is it is previously
developed the remnants of which can be
seen on the side
it is also surrounded on two straight
free sides by commercial and residential
uses and so is not an isolated area of
Countryside and development would not
harm the local landscape or communities
and finally in respect of policy
it is our view this proposal does accord
with policy as-10 of the core strategy
whilst the policy officer's view is that
proposed is not small scale
there is no definition of what is small
scale and each each case has to be
considered on its merits
however even if you were to agree with
officers that there is a technical
breach of as-10
there are good sign planning reasons as
outlined though that way what can only
be described as a limited a very limited
conflict with the development plan
we therefore respectfully request you
grant permission with appropriate
conditions thank you
very much indeed members do we have any
questions for our agents please
Council Harvey a very simple question
um if part of the argument in support of
this application is its Appeal on
employment grounds
can you say anything about the number of
jobs that might be created
this as the officer said this is an
outline application so that the scale of
the buildings isn't part of the
application but if you were to look at a
typical development of this size
depending on the nature of the
businesses employed but you could be
looking at somewhere in the order of 100
jobs
okay any other questions
no Mr Sims thank you very much for your
time contribution this evening
okay our last speaker on this item is
our award member councilor together good
evening councilor
you definitely know the drill you'll
have five minutes I'll give you 30
second warning whenever you're
comfortable and ready to go if you press
the button in the middle the floor is
yours
thank you chair good evening
call Members so as you already heard the
site is contained within a much larger
site of 27 Acres which currently
comprise 14 Caravan peaches but also I
understand a waste Transfer system a
repair Workshop is keep higher business
and therefore can be characterized as a
rural employment site next to the site
there is a larger Self Storage business
with several warehouses
this locality represents a
semi-industrial commercial area
The Proposal would contribute to the
diversity of our rural jobs in a world
where traditional local employment sites
such as the long Marston Airfield and
the engineered airport Naomi unveil have
been or are in the process of being
mainly developed for housing
we have recently lost two Horticultural
businesses in the Parish of Welford as
well to housing hundreds of houses are
being built in our area but there isn't
enough rural employment provision
the proposed expansion of this business
can provide some jobs for those living
in the settlements in my world
and Beyond
there is support in the mppf for
businesses in rural areas and the
council's emerging site allocation plan
also supports rural employment sites
the economy including rural-based jobs
is one of the four key strategic issues
for the South Watershed local plan and
locally The Proposal meets one of the
neighborhood development plans
objectives which supports an expanded
range of business activities through
excellent infrastructure
looking at the core strategy this
proposal meets the Strategic
requirements of both policies as10 and
cs-22 economic development
policy as-10 clearly indicates that to
help maintain the Vitality rural
communities and of the rural economy
provision will be made for a wide range
of activities and development in rural
parts of the district
and paragraph n supports extension to a
business in its established location
particularly if it would be a reasonable
to expect the business to relocate in
order to expand
the location is served by the bus 27 and
being located just outside the village
of long Marston the applicant has agreed
as we have heard to provide a footpath
from the site to Long Marston as well as
an additional bus stop
these have been approved by highways too
and which has no objections to The
Proposal
further policy cs22 is an objective to
maintain a sustainable balance between
employment growth and housing provision
the sustainable Community strategy of
the council states that our rural areas
will be providing more businesses and
jobs well this is a rural business which
aspires to grow and would provide local
employment opportunities and the four
interns will support local services
there are no objections from all the
technical consultants most importantly
including highways and the local flood
Authority there is support from the
world member the parish council as well
as the county councilor the neighboring
Parish Council and I understand too that
the officer was working on the basis
that it was going to be a delegated
approval in conclusion members this is
previously developed lunch there are
other types of similar businesses now
operating from The Wider side and in the
surrounding locality the proposed
footpath and bus stop which will greatly
improves connectivity would have
benefits for The Wider Community too as
the facilities in Long Marston can be
easily accessed and it won't impact on
the character of the local area before
its locations should not be ground for
refusal I hope therefore that you will
grant permission tonight so that we can
get the sustainable balance between
housing and employment back on track in
this rural world with any appropriate
conditions of course such as in relation
to landscape and Boundary thank you very
much
cancer thank you very much indeed
members we have any questions for our
Ward member Council Dixon
with your local knowledge
there's obviously uh this site is within
a complex of other industrial or
commercial units do you know what the uh
land was
around this site prior to those units
being constructed it's going back
possibly a number of years I don't know
okay so I'm I'm not sure about that but
I know that it was previously in um
or nurseries so an Horticultural
business so in that sense is previously
developed land it was already employment
uh an employment site
um and as councilor Hockaday
um as pointed out we had lost some
Horticultural businesses in our world
but in the planning applications they
were seen as Brownfield sites so thank
you Council Crump
um just getting your your local
knowledge would be handy here
um I think if you're bad with me there
is a questions coming through
um have you in the idea of the
employment rate locally
um because on many organizations are
both in the public and private sector
are harmful recruiting and retaining
staff
um
so
my question is I'm concerned that it we
want sustainable employment so if if
you've got full or quite near full local
employment
potentially staff might have to be
imported in
um after travel use the car so just
wondered what your thoughts were on that
please
yeah thank you Council Camp actually a
very good question we as you might be
aware we have the uh the myON Vale
development that's been built and that
was supposed to be 500 houses originally
but it's um it's now when it will be all
built 1
000 and when more than one thousand
hours it was 50 more hours in there and
and that is mainly you know we the
demographics that is young families
coming in moving in so there will be
they will be looking for jobs and again
I got the long Martin Garden Village as
well next door
um and that that's been built right now
and if we uh the first 400 houses have
been approved and if you know the
infrastructure issues
um are addressed then there will be 3
500 houses so it's a big settlement so I
think uh you know there won't be
um shortage of uh of people looking for
jobs and with the connectivity that
would be quite good because then we can
have active travel to to a place of work
of course I you know I can't see in the
future but I can see that if you want to
make if you want to cut on carbon
emissions then you know you need to
provide jobs close to these new
settlements
thank you Council Jennings please
I'm not sure what this is going to be
one for the officers or not but you may
be able to answer it with your local
knowledge
um it's the owner of the business to the
South also the applicant here
perhaps we can revert to the offices I I
I'm assuming from the look on Council
please the answer she doesn't know
so we'll we'll refer that to the
officers any other questions for our war
member before we move on
no cancel both guys thank you very much
okay let's move to questions or points
of uh clarification with our officers
who would like to kick us off councilor
Jennings
is the is the the buildings to the south
of this the business the same applicant
here
um no this is Australia answer if you
know it's in the report it says about a
letter was submitted from the owners of
the Self Storage site that they might be
interested in version of land but as
highlighted in report we obviously can't
guarantee that would be the case at this
moment in time but the answer didn't
know okay I have a further question but
it's slightly different but
um is this Brownfield land
same again if you have a look in the
officers the principal section of the
report especially under where it says a
previous appeal so this refers to the
2015 appeal it goes into previous
developed land and for the reason set
our body inspector and how the
definition came about it is defined as
Greenfield land so it is not considered
previous development Land from the
inspectors decisions that appeal
Council Adam
uh Joe I was wondering I
I mean part of Castle Jennings question
uh question was answered one of mine
um but I think uh one of the main things
with the as10 definition is
um being pointed out a small scale can
you give me where that definition is
kind of gathered from and and how we can
associate the scale of what's being put
in front of us relating to the text as
it were uh
it's kind of it has to be a matter of
fact to the degree of every application
there is no definition of small scaleed
uh Mr Stevens is absolutely right so
that's how at the same time we have to
consult with planning policy because for
obvious reasons there's only right the
policy in this instance it is 1.8
hectares or two land in open Countryside
that isn't considered the previous
development land and therefore it
wouldn't con astute on a matter of fact
degree for this application to be small
scale the honest truth being there is no
set definition you have to do it on a
matter of fact and agree with 1.8
hectares to be considered up crunch side
and a policy objection it's been
determined that this isn't being a small
scale
quick follow-up um what's a slightly
different
maybe speculative do you know what a
potential fallback position would be for
this site because this is clearly
you know unintended uh currently it's
all just brush and scrub so it what you
see is the fullback position for any
sort of development unless you've met
the policy criteria under age 10 of
possibly image moves going over
Countryside there is no fallback
position it's Greenfield Landing the
open Countryside
Council Curtis
okay
um
policy cs22 refers to existing
employment sites
this obviously has been a previous
employment site is is there a sort of
definition of when an existing
employment site is no longer an existing
employment side that you know is there
does it have to be vacant for six months
five years before it is no longer an
employment is there some clarification
on that no you're going down to a lot of
once again case law defines it of a
matter of fact degree of each site so in
this instance you've got them there's
already been one application which made
it for this site in 2020 which
highlighted the previous Reasons from
the appeal decision so you have to keep
falling back on the last decisions The
inspective Fallout appeal decision said
this site is Greenfield land and
therefore is not previous development
and therefore for that instance although
there might have been very historic
sites that might have used part of land
for employment sites the entirety of the
site through that appeal decision and
the 2020 application as the finders is
Greenfield open land and net
applications for a new business in the
open Countryside
the inspector is a material plan
consideration from it
Council before I bring you in I'm going
to just I just want to tease a little
bit more out of that presumably if the
land had had a business use at some
stage which we're being led to believe
in judging from the pitches it possibly
has it would have had a use class put on
it do we know what that use class is
is same again if you go into your
appeals decision that Gordon thought it
was basically an agricultural use class
not as what is determined from the most
relevant last appeal decision
technically and I must highlight this
that can only really be determined
through a lawful development certificate
really on going on one of the aspects
his bill decision is the only way we
conclusively say that is if the lawful
development certificate was submitted to
the council to investigate the last use
whether that is in bacon whether it's
still considered in use because you and
referring to a lot of case law
this at the minute hasn't been submitted
love to answer difficult so you go on
the material planning situations before
you last one is the appealed and then
also the last application lovely that's
clear thank you councilor Harvey
thank you can I refer to page seven of
the um of Mr Brooks report and he makes
the point uh contrasts
a new business as opposed to not a new
business
um
could Mr Brook tell us
um how big that factor or that
consideration was in weighing up his
recommendation and or to put it another
way had this been an existing business
what would impact the impact has been on
his recommendation
thank you
um I I have to highlight this is a lot
of it's hypothetical because obviously
every application is a matter of fact a
degree that's before you so it's quite
different the problem
if it wasn't existing employment site
then and it obviously then it could be
the DM and it was PDR which is previous
developed land which then comes down to
other policy criterias the honest truth
is I can't really answer that question
because it's different policy criteria
it's been assessed with the inspector's
decision and the 2020 application as
being open Countryside and not previous
development
if it was previous to that in London it
wasn't existing business on there then
you would do an assessment of the new
business coming onto the land it would
is it like for like is it more domineer
in the existing business all out in this
case I can't do that assessment because
it's technically open concise and not
being previous without land
yeah just a very quick one Joe I think
it's probably a typo um
page six
um we've got back granted application
where it says
um
the welfare don't even know about plan
policy hd5 Etc a bit further down in the
so I assume that plan has been approved
because a bit further down it says as
well as the emerging longitude
neighborhood development plan so
I assume it has been a basically if you
have a look that's I presume you were
saying the background application
yeah I've got back then a bit further
down on principal development says the
consideration is a commit key material
consideration as well as the emerge and
long agent and iPod development
apologies you're absolutely right it's a
typo so it's definitely been it's gone
through it apologies it's a tiger yep oh
good man thank you
okay anyone else I've got two and
Council Foreman
I think we were going to clarify the two
thousand pounds uh legal fees paid to
Stratford that was mentioned I don't
think we're going to clarify the two
thousand pound legal fees because we're
not able to do that what we were going
to clarify and it's on my list so thank
you for bringing it up
um an s106 agreement it was alluded to
by a couple of our speakers that
um potentially were moving towards
delegated approval
is that correct as a 106 minutes into
and if so why
so
I have to go to the room when the
application come in so I can give you
the background behind it you've got to
remember the 2020 application was
refused for two reasons
my objective as a planning officer is
always try and get the best scheme
that's possibly come forward one of the
reason was it wasn't it well integrated
with long Mars and a wide field the
African rightly put forward a footpath
and a bus stop for that to be deemed
successful I have to be 100 sure that we
could integrate them now it's outside
the red line boundary which I won't go
into the whole remix of it that makes it
very complicated and convolution legal
agreements were then sought with our
legal team to see if a 106 had to
establish whether we could and this is
in the report whether we could have to
do that through a 106 or could it be
done through a grumpy and condition this
is a reason a legal team got involved
after Merchant negotiations and still
especially me going back with highways
it was determined that could be done
through grampian conditions but we had
to have our legal officers involved and
106 is at one point looked like it was
going to have to be drawn up in the end
it wasn't the grampian conditions were
considered to be acceptable if you know
that's now not a reason for refusal the
reason for refuse the size of
development and that's how it's come
about so in short you're following a
process to ensure that uh something has
been put forward to overcome a previous
reason for refusal you're going through
that process that required you to
research whether an x-106 or ramping
conditions were required so it doesn't
automatically mean you're looking to
delegate I'm assuming you are never
looking to oh the negotiations with the
agent was obviously trying to get the
best scheme but at the same time it was
always highlighted that we are out in
consultation with policy I would always
go back and I did go back to policy and
say I'm satisfied they've overcome that
reason for refusal so that it wasn't
well integrated but do you still want to
maintain the objection on the size of
the site negotiations always hold policy
have maintained that objection is the
reason why we've come to planning
committee understood that's very clear
thank you um unless anyone else has any
more I have got one other written down
that was brought up for earlier on
councilor Adam first
sorry I'm looking at you strangely I I
was seeing if your microphone was on
some of them aren't clicking
um page seven third paragraph it
mentions in the inspectorates assessment
uh containing agricultural buildings as
being part of your assessment of it
being Greenfield land
the photos indicated that there weren't
substantial buildings there albeit that
it's been pointed out there were some
there previously which is the fact that
they may not be there now re impact on
that at all
it certainly could do but once again it
has to come back to the lawfulness of
the use and that can only be established
through a lawful development certificate
so basically you have to establish
whether that use is no longer in use and
as a ceased
now demolition could certainly establish
that but at the same time just because
the buildings are partly demolitioned or
anything like that does not mean through
case law that the use is no longer
agriculture the only way to define that
is through local and certificate so this
moment of time that's why I reference
the inspector's decision
okay I've got one more uh question if I
may again our speakers alluded to our
current employment land status whether
we do or don't have sufficient uh
employment lands put aside for for the
future of the district can you Enlighten
us to what exactly that status is and
how much weight one should give it in
the planning balance so you have to go
on in requirements with planning law in
accordance with the areas development
plan so at this moment in time the areas
development plan is the core strategy
and the evidence-based documents that it
contains so actual adopted documents at
this moment in time is the stuff that
writes the core strategy
the character is very right to allude to
that we're in the process of doing the
South local Warwickshire plan which has
new documents and Land staying up but
that local plan at the minute is a very
limited stage it's not gone through its
elimination it's not even gone through a
few constations so it carries limited
weight in the determination of
obligations we have to go with what is
the development plan strategy
okay thank you very much let someone
else have any questions for
clarification we'll move to debate who
wants to kick us off councilor Jennings
all right this is one of those which you
are which I think we all hate
um I think logic says to us
um and it's technically open Countryside
but certainly doesn't look like it and
we all we all appreciate there's a
shortage of employment land and it would
make absolutely logical sense to to put
something in there I'm on this side and
I'm looking but again we have to do
everything on material planning we have
we've got a we've got our policies for a
reason
I'm going through as10 and the reason I
asked whether it was the next door
neighbor who owned it I was then sort of
clutching at straws to then say go well
it would be an extension to a business
but it's not so again that one's ruled
out and I'm I've been going through all
of these and I'm I'm trying to I'm
desperately trying to find that needle
in the haystack or reasons that I can
support this but at the moment I'm I'm
really struggling because we have to do
this we have so we have rules to follow
I'm not proposing anything at this stage
those are my initial thoughts so throw
it out there
thank you Council Jennings Council
Kendall please thank you chairman
um I think I'm in agreement with
councilor Jennings and also thank you to
Joe for explaining especially inspector
uh in the inspector's views and of
course all the previous case all that
really helped me
um going off that I am satisfied that I
that this is is although it may not look
like it it is Greenfield land
um and as such I can't find any grounds
to go against the
uh the officer's recommendation
um so I I'm happy to propose that we
refuse the application based on that
thank you very much councilor Adam
please
there you go thank you um I think based
on the responses we've had from the
officer here's a technical assessment is
appropriate
the issue I have is that there's a sort
of Common Sense argument that I think
councilor pemberton's uh response that
we had tries to flesh out uh and in
trying to assess this more on sort of a
balance and sort of a practical basis
one of the reasons I asked for a
potential fallback was to see if there
was anything that we could rely on
outside of the technicality of this
argument really I think we've sort of
satisfied ourselves that there isn't any
um room to maneuver in terms of his
assessment however
when considering this and particularly
in in relation to the the feedback we've
had from the parish council award member
the county councilor and in my view
which is quite important the cpre
I see that the material risk to granting
a permission on this site is
substantially
lower than we would normally hold as a
threshold
uh in that I mean effectively we're not
likely to have well we can't have a an
appeal effectively on a grant
and so the rest of the council
and the precedent that would be set
would be
acceptable in planning planning balance
from my point of view I'm not going to
propose anything as of yet because I'd
like to mull that around the uh the
committee and probably the legal officer
as well
but that's my feeling at the moment
because there is a sense of feeling I
feel from the local representative so
this is a good thing for the
bear Ward there and the area in the
district that's my feeling I'd like to
find some way to support it on that
basis thoughts are welcome
okay thank you so I'm Council Dixon next
please
thank you chairman
I agree with councilor Adam
um
this I I get the distinct feeling that
the reason that the planners have gone
this route is because of planning
inspectors comment
planning inspectors are but one
individual my understanding they make an
assessment and they make an
interpretation
quite understand how they look at a site
and their opinion on that site
planning inspectors can be wrong
we've had planning inspectors give
appeals against this Council which we've
taken to the high court and succeeded
and won so planning inspectors can be
wrong and I don't think we should be
driven tonight by making the decision
which is being led I think by an
inspector's comment where previously I
think we have regarded this land as
Brownfield land and then inspector has
said no it isn't
because it's previously developed
agricultural land and it always remains
agricultural land because possibly got
agricultural buildings on it and nothing
changes that
now as I say I think the planning
inspectors can make an error so I would
be like to see this one granted
um on that basis I'll I'll shut down
okay just so I I'm clear are you
proposing a grant
I will but I then got to try to find my
reasons something you do need to find
your reasons if you can come up we can
come back to that we obviously have a
proposal to refuse already if that's
seconded we take that first if yours is
seconded we'll take that first but I
need your reasons before we take it
um councilor Harvey please
I mean with most of the other councils
it appears I would really really like to
be able to say yes to this for all the
reasons that have been put forward I
think I think the case in a common sense
way is made uh very well
um however uh we have a responsibility
to respect the Integrity of of the of
the of the policy that we have and
that's what the officer has done in
making his recommendation and I take
councilor Dixon's point of view that
planning inspectors can be wrong but I
think I'm I'm minded at the moment to
refuse on the basis that provides an
opportunity for an appeal for another
planning inspector
sort it out
Council Mills
thanks Mr chairman yeah um
I just hope that Common Sense prevails
on this one
um I mean it will bring employment to
the area and as I said before it is a
scruffy old site isn't it and it can be
left like that and it improves the look
um I like the idea there's a bus stop
close to the um well proposed bus stop
or close to the development
um
I just hope common Century uh prevails
on this one Mr chairman I'm I'm will go
against the officer's recommendation
thank you
Council Foreman
thank you
um I'm also agreeing with councilor
Dixon and councilor Adams I think I'm in
favor of supporting this one I'm
thinking about what the ward member said
about the extra housing that's happened
in the area and the loss of businesses
already plus the foot path and the bus
stop
which is going to have a wider benefit
to the community as well so that's the
way I'm thinking at the moment
Council Crump
yeah this is a very difficult one um
certainly
it's it's got lots of merits and
sustainable and local jobs for local
people I'm sure that phrase has been
used somewhere before
um so lots of benefits and lots of
thoughts have gone into this and all the
issues regarding flooding sustainable
bus stops and that lots of Merit
around this application
but there's one problem that I've got
it's the um the policy we've got a
policy
um for a reason uh for development in
the
um Countryside you know it's it's been
talked about it on page seven
um at the appeal and previously
development or well it's not previously
development so therefore I'm not I'm not
convinced
we should be going against our policy
because we've got our policies for a
reason
um we touched upon
um
and it's in in two parts it's not just
ourselves
um but also in the Wellford one as well
hd5 so reluctantly I will be going with
the officer's recommendation on this one
can I just confirm it are you willing to
Second cancer Kendall's proposal
yeah I'll second up yeah Marvis thank
you Council Curtis next
year
um
yeah I agree with councilor Dixon and
others on this I think I would really
like to find a way
of granting this that we have seen
massive amounts of Housing Development
which hasn't really been matched by
local employment opportunities
this application has the support of two
Parish councils I think it's very
significant that it has the support of
the cpre
um I'm not disagreeing with the
officer's report which I think is
excellent and obviously you refer back
to the inspectors decisions
um but I just want to you know looking
at policy cs22 Economic Development I
wonder if is there some scope here this
um Clause of an existing employment side
is this still an existing employment
site and can we no I'm getting shot
I'll answer that straight away I think
on the basis of what the the officers
already said and and specifically on
page seven the inspectors report that
they considered to be Greenfield and
therefore no it is it is not an
employment site
but an employment a Greenfield site can
be in an employment side the two aren't
mutually exclusive are they
that I'm going to have to refer to our
officers
foreign
cultural use
can at times be referred to an
employment site because it's obviously
agriculture employs Farm it's not a lot
at the same time do you then allude to
that as you saw is open at the minute
the appeal decision was in 2015 writing
by the nurseries was before is
Greenfield London the PDL I don't think
we could classify as an employment site
the reason I'm hesitant on that is it
goes back to lawful development it's
difficult for me to conclusively tell
you there's not an employment side it
would have to be done through a lawful
defense difficult
cancer Adam I suppose the only other
thing I can think of
um which I I know I touched on on my
questions and I'll probably ask Joe to
remind me
um the answer he gave then the scale and
it being small scale
I'm wondering if there's scope for
flexibility there because I mean
effectively the wording of it I think I
mean it's not saying that small scale is
X hectares it's saying scale and I think
that's effectively gives us
a way of looking at it within the
landscape
and particularly in relation to say the
neighboring site which when you look at
it on plan is not dissimilar and I also
wonder whether their neighboring site
was considered small scale when that
went up a little there's a bit of
precedent we can run there
um the small scale Point you're the
decision maker is in with your gift to
decide whether you think it's small
scale or not
so that is up to you to determine the
case officers but his point that he
doesn't consider it to be but if you
come to a different conclusion that is
within your gift
okay yep
um in that case I'd say from my point of
view it is small scale and that we could
justify on that basis and though
therefore I'd propose to go against the
officer's recommendation
I'm gonna need something a bit more than
that but let me come back to that in a
second we we've gone around the houses
quite a lot here Council James last
chance on this one and we do have a
proposal I'm going to take that in a
minute
so it's just for clarification of the
office from the officer on when small
scale keeps on being mentioned here I'm
looking at the core policy at the moment
page 193 business M but it says the only
place where I can see small scale is
small spell small scale expansion of an
existing group of buildings and
there aren't any buildings on this land
is that correct or is there another
small scale which I hadn't been able to
spot no no the smaller scale expansion
so power and is small like it didn't
existing business it was already on the
land so let's say the storage unit
wanted to expand their site
then you'd have policy n of as10 sorry
part n of as10 and also that sort of
expansion for it
sorry I'm getting some guidance from our
office as well in my ear um
we've I think everyone's had an
opportunity to speak about for me so far
um which is rare
um
Council Dixon is yours a short point
because I've got you indicator I think
councilor Harvey indicated I think has a
Curtis also indicated I want to be quick
I was just coming back on basically you
wanted some reasons okay let me come to
that in a minute sure
um Council that Harvey did you indicate
and please make it very quick very quick
um the question for me ultimately is the
Integrity of the core strategy thank you
councilor Curtis do you have anything
else okay I'm going to try and sum up as
best I can if I may I get the impression
that most people around the table are
looking for reasons to approve
as councilor Harvey has already
indicated and I would hardly agree with
this we have policy for a reason
um it is to protect the district for
whatever form of development it might be
if we were to go against this uh on a
whim then I hope that it's okay or as
counselor uh Adam alluded to because
there's no risk to the Council of an
appeal I think I said wholly the wrong
thing to do because it does then call in
to question the Integrity of our core
strategy that's the real risk to this
Council so we have to bear that in mind
if we're looking to Grant if members are
looking to Grant I've already heard from
a couple that you are
we need to consider the scale that's one
of the reasons for refusal it is within
your gift to decide whether you think it
is small scale or not if you think it is
say so if you don't say so
it's then a question of it for me anyway
it's a question of whether this is
Brownfield or Greenfield land we have an
expected decision that has determined
that this is Greenfield land that would
therefore fail our policy tests we also
know that it has been used
as a nursery in the past now it is then
within your gift to determine whether
you think it is as a result Brownfield
land and therefore could potentially
look to Grant I'm not saying that is the
right thing to do
but that is something you can consider
so with that in mind
we have had a proposal to refuse in line
with the officer's recommendation that
has been seconded we have had a proposal
to Grant and we'll go through the
reasons for that if we need to but I had
I don't believe that secondary I think
councilor Adam might have proposed it a
second time can I just confirm are you
would you be seconding councilor Dixon's
proposal to Grant I think I proposed it
and I was looking for a second I so I'm
going to disagree with you on that I'm
afraid I did but what I will do oh did
you okay okay so what I will do out of
courtesy is allow you to Second it so
we'll we'll assume that has been
seconded from councilor Adam and we can
come to that in a minute if it's
required we do have to take the proposal
to refuse first
so the proposal is to refuse in line
with the offer as a recommendation can I
please have a show of hands for those in
favor of the refusal
four and those against
five I think
one two three four five
and abstentions one okay so that
therefore fails so we now need to flesh
out the reasons why Council Dixon's
proposed Grant cancer Dex number to you
but the reasons I was looking at here is
and then I'm not looking at references
in restaurants obviously there's a
benefit for the local community
there is that by way of
employment opportunities for local
residents
whether or not there any residents
seeking employment there is another
matter but there will be employment
opportunities two there will be a
footpath provided
Etc which will serve not only this
development if it is approved but also
the other next door neighbors
development therefore that too is an
improvement an enhancement for the
community it will create a an employment
site within a rural area
not a main town
and if I come to the officer's
conclusion and I'm now looking at page
16 where Joe writes it is acknowledged
that the provision of the additional
Industrial Development would provide
benefit to the local economy through the
provision of employment opportunities
however due to the location of the site
and its Greenfield status these benefits
in his opinion
failed to outweigh the in-principle harm
and would result in an unacceptable form
of development
I can disagree with his uh
assessment there and comfort and
conclusion and I would say well actually
I think the employment opportunities and
the improvements for the local economy
are do outweigh the Greenfield status of
this site
Council Adam do you want to add anything
to that
uh well as I've already expressed my
opinion of the scale I'd have done if it
were me but I'm quite happy to support
it as a second now just on a personal
note as well I would say I don't take
the Integrity of the core strategy
lightly and I although I may have been
slightly flippant in my initial remarks
um I think the material risk of the
council is obviously a part of the
material conditions between behind what
we make decisions on uh committee and
that's um always in my mind
so just to recap what I've heard there
and forgive me if I've missed something
um
key thing is the employment opportunity
and the employment that it provides to
to the locality and then it's an
enhancement of the area by virtue of
clearing the site tidying it up and
putting the path in
that's it
yeah
so with that I think and was that cancer
Council Dixon Council Dixon with that I
think we need to flesh out a little bit
more I may have alluded to two things
that you would want to add into your
reasons
and that you consider it to be small
scale
previously employment yeah there we go
okay
um officers you've heard our reasoning
are you comfortable that they are sound
reasons
if not I'll throw in an extra one
[Music]
I I think that's
been some valuable discussions over the
scale
um as councilor Richards has already
said it's up to you to determine how you
want to interpret that
I would be concerned about making a
judgment on the Brownfield land without
the the definitive evidence to support
that through lawful development
certificate which is what Joe has
already suggested so at this stage I
don't feel comfortable
a castle candle I'll just be brief I'm
just gonna have my thoughts I've got I'm
uncomfortable with the wording that we
think that the employment outweighs
any harm in losing Greenfield sight
because if that was part of our wording
I hate to think how that would be used
in future in other situations and could
completely undermine our core strategy
because you would just make the case
this benefits employment in the area and
before you know we're building
everywhere so I I cannot I'm really very
comfortable with that as a word as a
specific wording here I think
I think Smalls I think how we interpret
small scale is for me that I'm not going
to vote for it but you know I think
that's how I would prefer that we went
if that's my view
bear with me just a sec
okay this is a nice easy one to start us
off brilliant
um
short of having a lawful development
certificate to prove that the site is
Brownfield I'm a little uncomfortable
in suggesting that it's whilst it's
within your gift to suggest that it is
and within our gift of decision makers
to agree or disagree I'm very
uncomfortable with that um there's no
clear evidence to demonstrate that it is
Brownfield
you can maintain that if you wish
um what I would say is that um the uh
the employment benefits overcoming the
uh the sighting of this could be
considered uh sufficient to overcome
that that it's worth and I'll read you a
passage from course UCS 22. it's worth
considering they say requirements for
businesses in business investment in the
district that are not specifically
catered For elsewhere in this policy
will be considered thoroughly and will
be supported where the economic and
social benefits of an individual
proposal outweigh any specific harm
likely to be caused
so if you consider the benefits that
this will bring will overcome the
sighting I.E being on Bloomfield land
you could in theory apply that policy am
I right in assuming that that is what
you're trying to say in your proposal
yes good
thank you chairman
okay I think we've got somewhere
I think you're you've you've got sound
reasons now for us to go against your
recommendation we do need to talk about
conditions I'm going to assume standard
conditions are any additionals that you
need
political apology
um Standard time limit and because it's
an outline application so you have to
reserve Master implication and being
submitted on soft Landscaping including
boundary details Water Supplies to
question conditions by ecology for a
protective species and the avoidance
measures for great growth of newts
uh than the flooding recommendations for
drainage details and flooding plan
maintenance plan for the flooding 3M
good standards which is recommended and
plus CS3
environmental health conditions on noise
limits and working hours
then the conditional Garden the bus stop
as well as bowel mouth visibility space
and the footway and that would be the
recommended conditions
Council Dixon is there anything else you
want to add in conditions
no thank you chairman I think Joe's
already got that long list well prepared
marvelous Council Adam
no okay we have a proposal to Grant
which is going against the office's
recommendation for the reasons given
could I please have a show of hand slate
in favor of Grant
and that's five of those against
four and abstentions
one therefore committee resolves to
Grant application twenty two zero zero
zero five one out that is land off long
Master Road in Wellford upon Avon
let's move swiftly onto our next item
which is application reference
2201793 ful that is land off Chapel
Street in warmington
our presenting officers once again Jerry
Brook Joe the floor is yours
thanks chair let me just uh
[Music]
the site is located in the village of
warmington as indicated by the black dog
for you
the applications seeking planning
permission for the development of a
single local needs self-build dwelling
within the village of warmington in
accordance with policy cs15 and cs-16 it
should be recognized that warmington is
defined as an all of a settlement
the application is cited within the
warmington conservation area and in
close proximity the grade two listed
characters Cottage so let me just so
demonstrate get the most working
Cottage and the attached buildings
and aging uh in the set in the grade two
listed plow Public House which is also
30 meters to the South just there
dwelling would be set as seven meters to
Ridge and is proposed to be constructed
out of Natural Stone and slate with a
symmetrical layout for the fenestration
and a small intimate Courtyard the
application would permit the
installation of solar panels on the rear
slope as well as a ground Source heat
pump
this is the um floor plans for it's a
site in so I just quickly go through it
so obviously you can see the layout of
the dialing lawn area and this is the
parking area as part of the proposal and
it is in the description of development
the garage of the parking area would be
demolished and this would then be able
to facilitate the parking for closed
development
going on to site photos this is the
application site just behind the
headline so the street running down
this is the way and opposite the
application sites there's photos taken
inside it gives you the context of the
area as well
this is then facing out onto the main
road running through warmington uh you
can this is the dwelling Francis Road
this is a listed par win public houses
to the right of this dwelling
this is done facing the other way so you
can see to your left is the garage area
this would also then form the entrance
Point as shown on the layout plan this
this photo is taken to make sure that
you can conclude seeds term and this is
the dwelling next to the site Jason and
this is the garage which as part of The
Proposal would be demolished to
facilitate the parking
the application is for a two-story
bedroom dwelling and as a result does
not meet the identified need as set in
the warmington and alsco Parish plan
2018 therefore the application failed to
record the passes as10 and cs15 of the
Stratford core strategy furthermore
although the development plan does not
currently include adopted policy on
Pacific subject of custom and self and
build housing the proposed development
does not comply with its merging policy
policy sap 6 contained with the emerging
site allocation plan and while it's
given a significant way to the provision
of South Bill dwelling in the context
the character's shortfall of SCB plots
solving custom build are set out in the
officer report it is considered the
development is an acceptable in
principle there are no updates thank you
Joe thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker on this item who
is councilor Mark burstell chairman of
warmington and alsco Parish Council
good evening and welcome
you've got a good idea of what's going
to happen I think you've been here
before we've seen you before you'll have
three minutes I'll give you 30 second
warning whenever you're ready press the
button in the middle and the time is
yours
thank you chairman uh can you hear me
all right
okay thank you uh at the previous
planning hearing for this application uh
it was rejected only at that time
because of concern about the garages
that were then included
these have now been removed from the
current application and that objection
can no longer stand
I'd like to talk about need there's a
clearly demonstrated need here the
applicant currently lives with his
mother and is her nominated carer
he now wishes to get married
so need somewhere else to live that is
still close to his mother so that he can
continue to support her
the application site is immediately
opposite whose mother's house on the
other side of the road
now for the parish Clan the plan was
created following two entirely different
surveys
the first was a housing needs survey
which was a requirement which looked at
the need for affordable housing
the second was a specific survey carried
out by the planish parish plan committee
which asked a number of questions about
people's wishes and views
on page seven of the parish plan there
is a note that 64 percent of residents
were in favor of some small-scale
development and pointed to an unmet need
for certain types of housing to enable
residents to remain in the village
page nine of the plan carries the
following statement in relation relation
to the housing needs survey
the survey uncovered one person in need
of affordable homing
of the 18 written comments only one was
definitely against more homes but two
felt there was no room
all the others were in favor of a
limited range of well-designed homes
suitable for families for older people
and those just starting out
so this application clearly meets the
desire identified in the adopted Parish
plan to have a few additional smaller
properties within the parish in order
for existing parishioners to remain in
the parish
core strategy cs1 sustainable
development States in determining
planning applications the particular
circumstances of the individual case
will be assessed to establish the
relative weight that should be given to
each aspect of sustainable development
the application is clearly designed
sustainably you've seen the details
cs11 for the Cotswold aonb States
small-scale development and activities
are appropriate in accordance with
policy as-10 Countryside in villages but
must not harm the historic or built
character local distinctiveness or
landscape quality of the aonb
the following forms of development use
in the countryside are acceptable in
principles small scale schemes for
housing employment or Community
facilities to meet a need identified by
local community in a parish plan
there have been no objections from
Neighbors only a comment about possible
excavation
this will be a self-built project local
use requirement the application has the
full support of the parish council and
the ward member thank you spot on three
minutes thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions Council
Dixon first
thank you chairman
um
you in your comments there you mentioned
that the survey was uh seat the the
wishes and the views of the residents
uh the report on my reading and I'm sure
you've read the officer's report
yourself makes reference to the fact
that it doesn't comply with policy
because it's a two-story house and not a
bungalow
um is that your interpretation of the
officers report as well well it's my
interpretation of the officer's report
but not of what it says in the parish
plan
if I may follow the parish claim
specifically says bungalows
housing needs survey mentions Bungalows
the rest of the parish plan does not
thank you
Council Crump
I think councilor Dixon and myself are
looking at the same page and with the
same questions almost yet mine was
around the parish plan
um which mentioned you mentioned 64
percent
of residents
um want to stay in the village or no it
was 64 would welcome some small-scale
development and part of that is to
enable residents to stay under Village
yes um are the downsize or of young
Farmers is that correct yes so just so
we're clear in the report it says a
housing survey was conducted by
Warwickshire Royal Community Council
do you recognize what they are saying
and
and you're because you're saying that
you want you're looking for limited and
small scale development of houses of
different sizes as opposed to the three
one bedroom Bungalow only occupies and
one times four bed bug grow
so any reason why there's the difference
between the two please well I think the
reason is that there were two entirely
different surveys carried out
the one was the housing needs survey
which we have to carry out in order to
have a parish plan
the second was the very detailed survey
that the parish carried out which asked
a number of questions about what people
wanted to see in the village how they
would like to see any development were
they against it and so on
a committee then went through all the
responses
counted up everything and came to a
various conclusions which I've tried to
highlight for you and there are
conclusions that come from what the
parish asked and different ones that
came from what the housing needs survey
asked
we've done one item we've got a lot to
get through and I've got to get this
right though so we've got to get this
right so you're saying that
your survey has been incorporated into
your Parish plan yes yes thank you
very concise perfect cancer Adam nope
Council Curtis
yes thank you when was the parish plan
survey carried out please
that was
originally sorry now I just prefer to
the dates
there were actually two surveys the
second survey was in 2012.
okay any more questions for councilor
burst or please no in that case come
special thank you very much for your
time and your patience this evening
okay our next speaker on this item is Mr
Tim Eastwood our applicant good evening
Mr eastwoods
so you've got a good idea of what's
Happening three minutes I'll give you 30
second warning stay seated for questions
afterwards when you're ready press the
button in the middle and the floor is
yours
I've um
I'm putting forward for a two-story
house because the the side is quite
small and to have a bungalow there it'd
be all house no Garden or very small
Bungalow and some Garden
um
there are houses in this Village
warmington to story whatever with old
people and they've got stair lips as as
my mother's house and they manage
perfectly well so in terms of needing a
bungalow
for all people to access the rooms in
the house with a stair lift it's proven
that in warmth and there are old people
living perfectly well
um
also the
a two-story house done in the style to
replicate the houses in the village and
I actually live in this Village they're
my neighbors and I would make sure the
house is built very sympathetically and
would fit in and I think it'd be it's
fair to say it would look better than
having a bungalow
um as regards to buying a house to stay
in the village
ex-council house cheapest house at 500
000 which is out of my price range
um as already said my personal
circumstances
I need to be there to take care of my
mother so um living with my mother and
being married is is isn't very suitable
as you can imagine
I think that's all I've got to say thank
you for your time
thank you very much indeed remember do
we have any questions for our applicants
no Mr Eastwood thank you very much for
your time contribution and your patience
okay we'll call our final speaker on
this item is Council John Fielding good
evening Council feilding
you are well versed in uh in this
process now so you'll have five minutes
please do take a seat you'll have five
minutes I'll give you 30 second warning
use as much or as little as the five
minutes as you like when you're ready
floor's yours
this may well be my last as I'm being
decommissioned in May so anyway there
you go
um
there was a house on this site which
fell into disrepair the applicant owns
the site and has been moving several
large routes that have destroyed the
front wall pushing the March into the
street
it was a danger to the public he sorted
that out
although the survey for the parish plan
was carried out
um I didn't hear the date that um
councilor verstel referred to
um the survey is still relevant it shows
that the support for additional
properties
the applicant has been living in the
village for 40 years and carries out odd
jobs for the community
he is his mother's carer and still lives
in her property but due to family
matters he would like to move
the site is on the opposite side of the
street it would allow him to carry on
being her carer
he's part of a large family and
therefore wants to protect his residency
in the village
he's proposing to get married
the case officer is satisfied with this
proposal it's small scale within SC10
as10 sorry
cs15 it complies with the local needs
components as set out in section 106.
the officer refers to sap 6 which also
highlights the local needs for this
property
sap 7 refers to installation and other
climate change requirements this again
is part of the proposal by the applicant
all the although the office
officer refers to sap six and seven the
officer agrees that it has little
carried little weight in this
application
the major hurdle that
prevented the amplification being
approved last time was the garage this
application proposes to remedy this
problem thus highways have now removed
its objection
highways objected last time and
consequently that was the problem one of
the major problems
the parish plan unlike the NDP
as and has limited weight as does as
sap6 both carry the same amount of
weight Limited the main principle of
this application meets the requirements
under section 106 providing a small
scale development for a person who's
been living in the community for a long
period Works within the community as a
carer and an odd job man and I would
like to see this application be granted
cancer feeling well within your time
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our Ward member
please
councilman Council Mills thank you thank
you councilor Fielding um you I'm not
sure this one for the uh
officer
um did you say there was a house on this
site previously there had been a site
there
uh what sorry
um when I got the
uh God the 1959 alternate survey from
um Tony perks and there was no house
then but I think there is a book written
about the village and it does refer to
this house being there so it was
probably at beginning of the 50s
member
no council building thank you very much
for your time contribution and your
patience to see me
okay members let's move to points of
clarification with our officers who
would like to kick us off with any
questions or points of clarification
Council Mills thank you Jim
um Joe um
it was has been refused due to the
garages and this has been addressed
hasn't it
um the garage has been moved back into
into the site
um I'll come what's that the only
objection
last time around so technically last
well there's been two applications that
have been refused the first one to come
to committee was refused on the two
instances also that it wasn't in
accordance with local need but during
that debate it was heavily debated about
the garage and the issues with highways
and then it came the both the reasons
were carried over but it was heavily
debated about the garage in the parking
area but it was refused on two grounds
the local need and the parking at that
time
Council Adam thank you thanks
um the
Parish Council mentioned that their
assessment of local need goes beyond the
survey conducted by orchard rural
community council because they conducted
a second survey which albeit was
slightly different in scope does that
get any weight in recognition for local
need for housing or are we obligated to
only rely on that specific initial
survey
you're not obligated by any stretch it's
just at the minute the way the positive
and Specialty part is the SPD as word is
it says that a housing need survey needs
to be supported
by a plan which is obviously the parish
plan so for that one to be carried over
it would then have to form the parish
plan if it did end up forming the parish
plan then certainly it would have
it would over supersede is probably
right away the original Harrison need
survey but the minute the Pirates plans
Horizon needs survey is the one
conducted by a Warwickshire rule
communities and that's how this
application was assessed
Council Crump yeah just going back to
that Parish plan
um from what I what I read and gathered
from the Paris Council that was that
part of the parish plan had the wrcc
information in which specified the three
times one bed and one times four bed
but the plan also contained their own
information which had contradictory
information so
there just seemed to be some disparity
between the two statements so that's
what I'm concerned about
I think the question is why is there a
disparity between the wrcc proposal and
the one the parish council alluded to
that appears to be contained in the plan
please make sure we ask questions
I I can't be here because the
performance of the Paris plan is it's
done by the Paris and it doesn't go to
Independent examination so the Paris
plans themselves are more conducted
through their own course and remit so I
can't really comment why is disparity
and if there was an inspectors
more
apologies
sorry about that
um it basically so I can't give you if
there was an inspector's decision I'll
be able to give you more clarity the
Paris plans the way they've done are
done through the Paris character
themselves and then form a material
planning consideration they do not form
as part of the adopted development plan
of the area so they do not carry the
same way as the core strategy on their
ndps do because they go for that whole
examination process what I would say is
the consideration is part is the SPD
requirements part s for local needs
where it says a house in need survey
through the support of the Paris plan or
Council and in this case the
Warwickshire raw house and need survey
was submitted and as part of the Paris
plan and that's where that assessment
has come through and that's how the
officer has undertaken that assessment I
hope that makes
sense just uh just so I can clarify this
in my head right
um
ultimately obviously as it would make
decisions in planning we need to have a
reasonable evidence based all that the
evidence that we have in front of us is
the wrcc housing needs survey that is
the most up-to-date housing needs survey
that has been applied through the parish
plan
um short of having a new because clearly
it has new survey as a snapshot in time
short of having a new
confirmed housing need survey done we
have to rely on the information we have
as part of the original at wrcc is that
right fundamentally yeah that's how it
is word in the SPD yeah lovely thank you
Council Harvey
yes on page 27 of the papers
say that
um the dwelling would be seen within the
existing built form and layout of the
village and would not cause undue harm
to the surrounding landscape or the
setting of the area of a standing
ashburton do you find it difficult to
come to that conclusion
uh no I I mean firstly I've got a
highlight I I dealt with the first
application but this report isn't my
report so it's too awesome assessment
but I appreciate I know the application
very well
from when I dealt with the application I
would say no it's in the village
confines
it's a reasonable standard dwelling it
respects the character of the area the
issue with it was principal development
I don't I fundamentally don't think it
would cause any harm to the A and B or
the character of the area
okay unless there are any other
questions or points of clarification
we're moving to debate who would like to
kick us off and debate councilor Crump
you want to concise you'll get pin size
one I support this application two
because I think it has to support the
local community internal Parish Council
responds to an identified need
it's a possible there's a chance that
there's be available to people with
local connection to the parish be small
small scale and meets the shortfall in
our self build plot which is a
significant factor so I propose we Grant
this application against officers
recommendation
thank you very much broken skies Council
Dixon next please
a second that proposal cancer Kendall
agreed anyone else
okay let's move to a vote then the pros
before I do I got a little bit excited
there forgive me
first of all
we've I think are pretty clear and
reason to go against officer
recommendation I'm assuming you're
comfortable that it is clear enough and
robust enough
um conditions
yes a standard time limit plans
materials Landscaping a hard and soft
Landscaping including boundary details
water butts uh so damage party for
climate change purposes ecology
conditions regarding the Swift nesting
Provisions highways Physicians regarding
the parking Provisions but I will load I
think that condition should also include
the demolition of the garage
um details for highways access pauses
Broadband obstacle grazing for bathrooms
one and two climate change checklist
levels uh will we actually put in
landscape condition
and that bins as well and permitted
development rights permitted development
rights to remove windows because the
rear elevation doesn't have Windows pros
and it may cause overlooking constraints
but that would have to be assessed at
that time
okay thank you anything you want to add
now you're happy as well consideration
you're happy
final wording obviously will be
delegated to officers obviously okay
good um proposal is to grant for the
reasons given uh could have a show of
hands for those in favor please that is
unanimous so committee therefore
resolves to Grant application 2201793
ful land off Chapel Street in warmington
right our next item is application
2201798 ful East Barn in Benton I will
be vacating the chair at this point and
handing over to councilor Kendall
I've just been reliably informed by our
officers that we also need to agree that
an s106 will be part of the previous
application so I am going to assume that
you're happy with that yes could have a
show of handfuls in favor of the s106
being drawn up by officers marvelous
that is confirmed
foreign
Church Bank Benton composer director
open sided freestanding Timber framed
carport uh presenting officer is Joseph
Brook Joe over to you thank you uh let
me just quickly get set up
oh where is my stuff
[Applause]
the site is located in the village of
Benton as indicated by the black dot for
you
the application is for a freestanding
open-sided carpool East house and the
attached car shed a grade 2 listed so
for context
and I will show you the obviously site
plan and stuff but it would be cited
there so this is Easter host night's
grade 2 listed and the shelter shed
which also then goes beyond the Curt
this is the room is also grade two
listed
uh Saint Peter's Church is also going to
listed as well as the Sundial and two of
the tombs within the church
this is the application site itself just
for more context so it shows the red
line boundary and where East house is
and the two listings
so this is the the planned of the
carport the carport is proposed to be
constructs out of hardwood frame Timber
boarding and a Timber shingle roof a lot
of the details our res is 3.5 meters so
3.5 meters in high to Ridge width at the
widest point is 4.9 meters length would
be 5.7 I'll just clarify that so it's
5.7 to the larger bit and it is 4.2 to
the second part there
this is the site photographs this is
where we sites this is the cart shed
which is grade two listed it would be
detached by about 0.7 meters from the
cart shed and it would obviously extend
outwards and that's where it would go
this is the grade two listed East Coast
this is basically taken front in the go
to these house where the cart shed would
be a large if permitted
this is then obviously the access into
um he said and
apologies again that is where it would
uh be cited uh coming out just outside
so it's basically there so you see the
Timberwolf defense in it would come from
the cart shed there and that is the
landscape in detail already exists
uh that's the end of it officer
recommendation is for refusal based on
the harm that it would cause to the set
in the listed buildings namely the cart
shed and East house as set out in the
officers report there are no updates
thank you
thank you Joe okay we've got our first
speaker that's Mr Tim Bishop please
good evening thank you for your patience
so far so you'll have three minutes
if you remain seated at the end for any
questions from the committee and would
you like the warning at 30 seconds
of course okay in that case over to you
good evening members of committee we're
seeking to build a small freestanding
open-sided wooden carpool for the
protection of our cars you'll note the
case officer has concluded that the
design and distinctiveness would be
acceptable in its location and is
supported by policy cs9 and the core
strategy
the only reason for refusal is a
perceived impact to the Heritage assets
specifically for the proposed carport
would be an unacceptable projection into
the former yard causing less than
significant harm this refers to cs-8
as members who are able to visit the
science store the space available for
the carport is limited and your officer
confirms this in the report at page 36
which has led to the sighting and layout
before you today
The Proposal is hardly visible from
outside the site or The Wider
Conservation area again your officer has
confirmed this at page 36 and it is not
visible from any public Road
as the custodians of the listed
buildings we believe our Modest Proposal
would cause no harm to our home its
setting all the Conservation Area
we've taken great care to ensure the
proposed carport is sympathetic and in
keeping with the historic buildings and
the surrounding area by using an
open-sided wooden structure with Timber
boarding and a low-pitched shingle roof
opposition is reinforced by the support
given to us by the ward member our
neighbors and the parish council and
there have been no objections from any
statutory consultations
indeed on page 37 the case officer
States I am satisfied that the
alternative construction materials
allows for an obvious visual
differentiation which allows the
historical listed buildings to maintain
their dominance and the carport will
visually appear as a continuation of the
built form along the northern boundary
we therefore believe our proposal is
supported by core strategy eight
uh CSA of the course registry sorry and
should be approved
members with the support from our
neighbors the parish council and the
ward member we trust that you will also
conclude that our Molly's proposal
causes no harm to the listed buildings
or its setting and that it allows for
the continued future viability of the
property by bringing it up to modern
living requirements thank you
thank you very much well within your
time as well any questions please from
the community is councilor Mills
hello Mr Bishop
um
the the
um shingle roof is it going to match the
um the barn that there's already there
the sugar roof won't match the roofing
on the barn but what we did offer in our
design and Heritage statement was if it
was more acceptable for clay tiles
similar to those on or in if we can get
them that is on the annex that we would
actually put those tiles on so so they
were all matched the annexed as far as
is possible yes super thank you very
much
councilor Curtis
thank you
um I have been to the site as I said
earlier on in these coaches of interest
but I just wanted could you just clarify
to the committee is there any other
space within the site
um that you could have a garage or
carport
we don't believe there is
um in in terms of it it's it is so tight
the space there for maneuvering cars as
well that is the only place that it can
go
thank you any other questions no that
case Mr Bishop thank you very much for
your time thank you
okay we've got our final speaker on this
application
our Ward member councilor Cargill
[Applause]
thank you members you know the drill not
five minutes whenever you're ready
thanks I didn't actually anticipate this
Community Committee so apologies for
that the application before you contains
a proposal from Modest carport within
the cartridge of the property the
residents are committed to maintaining
the quality of their home environment
and the last thing they wish to do is
harm it in any way report notes that the
wooden open wooden structure of the
carport will not be overly visible from
outside the site and I agree The Chosen
materials and design are intended to
blend as much as is possible into the
surroundings and in fact lead the eye
away from the Cars so that it is not jar
with a listed Barn
the rear Gardens including the cars and
carport cannot be seen from the public
road and there is only a glimpse of the
cars and the proposed carport from the
private road leading to the few
dwellings in that area and as has been
mentioned it's not been opposed in any
way
the courtyard is the resident's back
garden and you resemblance to the
original Farm quadrangle disappeared a
long time ago it's a well-kept area in
keeping with a cottage type Garden
demonstrating the care they take in
maintaining the property
there's a medley of items in the garden
including Planters and other Garden
paraphernalia and that is the first
thing you'll see as you enter the site
not the cars or the car proposed carport
we all accept parking of cars next to
listed buildings however that's
considered temporary by their very
nature we are not considering stopping
that of course if anything the added
carport will partially obscure the view
of the cars by softening the visibility
of them and leading the eye away
the officer's concern is the projection
of the carport into the courtyard and
the view that this causes less than
substantial harm to the listed building
there is only one location which I think
has been agreed in which to park the
cars and hence any one location for the
car port
in this case there needs to be a balance
between practicality and Ambiance I
believe this Design Falls fulfills that
Criterion
while on site I noticed that opposite
the proposed structure as a trellis made
in an open wooden structure that does
not in any way harm the list of
buildings in particular in particularly
obscures of your other house but is
acceptable being of a temporary nature
the carport is the same
as many around here I'm committed to
preserving Our Heritage and we also but
we also need to live in these historic
buildings the proposed structure like
the trellis is temporary if in the
fullness of time is considered
appropriate that the whole Courtyard be
returned to its original state then the
brick constructed garage at only a few
meters away given planning permission
will be much more difficult to remove
than a temporary open wooden structure
the design is considered acceptable as
is the minimum optimal viable use it is
not permanent structure it's designed to
blend as much as possible into the
courtyard is not attached in any way to
the listed building and considered could
be considered not to harm but
potentially ease a visual impact of the
park cars on the list of building
as with many applications relating to
Heritage assets opinions are subjective
and are planning balance
in conclusion I do not consider that the
carport does cause less than substantial
harm to the list of building meaning cs8
does not apply and therefore I ask that
permission is granted thank you
thank you councilor any questions from
the committee
no in that case thank you very much for
your time
okay
uh points of clarification have you got
any questions for our officers councilor
Mills thanks Mr chairman
um Joe the um
as you know I I did visit the site
um
we've got the the carport
what is the carport height compared with
the annex there it I can't see any
measurements I've got it wrong
dimensions
can't see any
there's no measurement uh so the ridge
height is 3.5 meters it still be set
down from the annex by about 1.5
okay got councilor Harvey next
um
page 37 makes a reference to
um an objection to this application on
the grounds that there are no public
benefits to outweigh the harm arising
we've been told that the the cardboard
can't be seen from the public highway so
I am struggling to understand what
public benefit the applicant could have
shown that would have satisfied this
condition could the officer help me out
uh the honest truth is you probably
there isn't a public event because
there's cardboard is specifically
designed to themselves so the reason
that's in is because it's a requirement
under listed building consent as well as
the mppf that you've got if there is a
public benefit that I always harm then
it can be at times approved in this
instance the conservation officers doom
and there is harm and there is no public
benefit so there's nothing to override
that harm that's the reason it's
referenced is is part of the assessment
under the conservation officers do is to
determine it could be anything from a
garage or even a new dwelling if there
is any public benefits that outweigh
that harm I don't think in this case
there probably would be that's the
reasons uh Heather's referenced it
okay I've got Council Adam next and I'm
going to go to council Jennings
directly linked to that
um sorry to jump the cue
um could a public benefit therefore be
that you see less of the car
yes
I mean
yeah in yeah yeah but yeah
yeah
as we go into the debate councilor Adam
thank you um just uh I think it was the
world member who mentioned uh potential
for a sort of a garage instead is there
a full back position you're aware of a
bit sort of intended by the applicant or
that you've sort of observed through the
application itself there's nothing I'm
aware of the as the officers highlighted
the previous applications within it I'm
not aware of the fullback position
okay if there are no more questions
should we go to the debate who wants to
kick us off
then I'll go over here
uh I think
having having a recognition for for
listed buildings is sort of something
that I think we should all be very aware
of and I know we've kind of been picked
up on it before I think I can appreciate
where the support for this application
is but my personal opinion is that there
is harm that has been identified by the
officers
um and that hasn't been uh significantly
outweighed and so I'd uh I think I'm
going to propose to go along with the
officer's recommendation thank you
Council Jennings
I am of the opposite opinion
um I think old and you can live together
um
we see it we see it all the time I think
it's a sympathetically designed
um and I would say that there's a public
benefit that you can see less of the car
but also I would say that I I also I'm
struggling to see any harm to the listed
building
and I would propose that we go against
the officer's recommendation and
uh ground
okay thank you uh Council Curtis
thank you and Joe thank you very much
for the report but I think um just
reading it
um the timber buildings can be
considered accepted in rural locations
I'm satisfied
um the alternative construction allows
for different visual differentiation
between the historical listed
new structures model on traditional
forms may be acceptable it visually
appears the continuation of the built
form I'm satisfied it will not be
visually in Congress there are awful lot
of things in here in this report where
really the report appears to be saying
it seems to be acceptable
um so
thank you very much it is a very good
report but I would support Council of
Jennings on this is that a formal
secondary yes why not thank you
okay got councilor Mills next
yes thanks Mr chairman I I go along with
the Council of General
um on this at when I did go and look at
the site I I couldn't see any material
harm there
um
and as Mr Bishop said it's going to be
sympathetically tied on from one of the
uh Patrick expection
um
I
I will go along against office
recommendation this Mr chairman I think
it Blends in very well as I said before
it cannot be seen from the road uh very
few neighbors can see it
um so there you are Mr chairman thank
you thank you councilor Foreman then I
come back to council Curtis
um yeah I'm quite happy with uh
councilor Jennings
um opinion I wondered if we should put a
condition on
on the vocal that way to have the tiles
matching the annex
I think they said that didn't they
they're getting happy with that yes
that's part of it I think isn't it uh
Council Curtis do you want to come back
that was exactly oh fine that's
brilliant anybody else want to speak in
the debate I think I'm agreeing with
Council Jennings as well
of course yes right okay I go over to
the officers so you've heard what the
committee said that you're content with
the reasons that have been given for us
to Grant to this application and then
secondly do you have any conditions that
go with it
the goal I'll give you the conditions in
a second it's it appears to me from the
discussions that councilors
um
Council Jennings on the condition of the
tiles I would suggest that we put
something closely matched or I can again
officer we leave that to the officer
that we should be putting closely
matched because
if counselors wanted
um a condition that you from what you've
said a condition that you may want to
include is that the materials are
submitted
um before the erection of the garage for
us to determine whether we feel that
they're acceptable yeah we'll take that
in mind okay are there any other
conditions going on right you have a
chance uh the conditions will be time
limit plans and materials scheduled
given the discussions
everybody happy yes excellent let's go
to the vote then uh the application has
been proposed that we grant for the
reasons given obviously with the
additional conditions mentioned all
those in favor of granting please show
those against
thank you therefore the committee
resolves to Grant application reference
22-01798 ful I'll invite chairman back
okay Council thank you very much for
doing that
um our next application is uh
application reference
2201440 ful is lower welcome Farm in
Smithfield and our presenting officer is
Sarah Flaherty Sarah as soon as you're
set up ready to go it's over to you
thank you chairman or just get my
PowerPoint up
thank you chairman this is a full
planning application for the conversion
of a barn to a dwelling the application
site is located two kilometers Southwest
of Centerfield in an open Countryside
location and is indicated by the black
dot on this plan
the barn forms part of a wider complex
which makes up lower welcome Farm which
comprises modern and historic farm
buildings and a farmhouse the site is
located in the green bar and Arden
special landscape area and has access to
our own existing track of the a46
here we see a proposed site plan the
barn subject of this application is
labeled Bane and could be seen here in
the center of the plan
and the demolition of a modern
agricultural building is proposed
buildings currently here it's proposed
to facilitate its conversion and create
space for a rear Garden the barn scene
here Bomb b was granted Planet Mission
earlier this year for conversion to a
dwelling
here we see comparisons of the existing
elevation of the bar at the top of the
slide and proposed elevations at the
bottom a number of root lights are
proposed along with the removal of the
traditional barn doors and replacement
with glazing so this slide shows the
front elevation the existing at the top
and the proposed at the bottom and this
shows the rear of a rear elevation
moving on to some photos this photo has
taken facing towards the west and shows
what is proposed to be the front
elevation of the proposed dwelling
the buildings are understood from OS
maps to date the late 19th century
this photo is taken facing the Northeast
and shows some of the details of the
barn such as the round brick window
detail at the end and the arched lintels
the parking for the proposed dwelling
will be located to the left of this
photo on the grass area and the modern
agricultural building can be seen to the
rear
this final image has taken face
is that working yep this image is taken
facing the southwest and shows the
modern agricultural building to be
demolished in the foreground with the
rear of the application barn on the left
chairman there is some conflict with the
principle of development
was The Proposal is capable of being
acceptable under policy as-10 of the
core strategy and NDP policy be 10
officers do not consider the proposal
meets the detailed wording of either of
these policies and that the barn is
neither redundant nor in disuse
the presented alternative scheme is not
considered a realistic fallback for the
reasons detailed in the committee report
in addition the proposed external
alterations to the barn are not
considered to be sensitive and are such
to not retain its historic and
agricultural character contrary to
policy cs9 of the core strategy policies
be3 and be10 are the NDP and part G of
the development requirements SPD
the recommendation is therefore to
refuse the application for the reasons
detailed on pages 52 and 53 of their
agenda thank you
Sarah thank you very much indeed now I
would normally call our first Speaker
who is the parish council However
unfortunately we've had notification
this afternoon is that the registered
speaker has tested positive for covet
and can't be here so we will show a
speedy recovery but I have her speech in
front of me and I will read that to you
now for baiting
uh as you can see from the playing
history there have been several planning
applications on this site conversion of
two barns was previously granted in 1990
and then renewed in 1996. however these
permissions then lapsed one of these
same barns was then granted permission
under reference
22-00143 ful as recently as the 21st of
March this year
both STC and the parish council
supported this application and it was
granted underdelegated powers
this new application for the second Barn
proposes a similar conversion the parish
council considers the provision set out
in be10 of the NDP supports this I.E
conversion of and reuse of existing
buildings
the parish council has made a site visit
and observed the brick Barn observed
that the brick Barn only housed
redundant old equipment and is not at
all suitable for the storage of hay or
modern machinery
the adjacent sorry the applicant
proposes to recite the adjacent modern
steel Barn to a nearby field for which
planning permission was granted and
1903077 agnot on the 6th of December
2019.
I apologize to everyone watching and
everyone in the audience as well for
this technical issues are rampant today
let me try again cpre have commented
that the proposed conversion is
reasonable however with some reservation
regarding the glazing to the to replace
the barn doors
in conclusion the parish council
considers that there is a net gain to
the openness of the green belt as the
adjacent steel Barn can be relocated
under permission
1903077 agnot and the brick Barn is
redundant which permits its conversion
under NDP be 10. clearly I'm unable
speaker who is Mr Mark Blackman who is
our agent good evening Mr Blackman
foreign
thank you very much for your patience as
you've probably worked out you will have
three minutes we'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up whenever
you're comfortable settled and ready to
go the floor is yours
good evening councilors thank you for
this opportunity to speak in favor of
the application you may recall that at
the previous committee meeting the
current case law is quoted in order to
demonstrate that the principle of this
Bond conversion in light of the um
excuse me the principle of This Barn
conversion uh is possible through the
committee the class Q route having read
the previous the planning officers
revised report I note that at no point
does it refer to the latest planning
case law to which I referred
the planning offices report does however
acknowledge that should this application
be refused there is a likelihood that
the applicant will pursue the class Q
route
at the point of originally submitting
this application it was specifically
raised with the planning officer that
the application could be submitted as
either a full application or as a class
queue I had hoped that since it was made
evident that the class queue was a
possible option that the planning
officer would see this as a backstop and
therefore enter into proactive
discussions if there were any design
issues
the planning officer taking this exact
approach on the previous application for
Bond B
the submitted class queue site plan
referred to in the planning officers
report was only provided as additional
evidence that the class queue route
represented a realistic Prospect and was
not intended to be put out for
consultation again the latest case law
states there is no rule of law that in
every case the real Prospect will depend
for example on the landowner having said
precisely how he would make use of any
permitted development rights available
to him
so there is no obligation on my client
to provide specific details only excuse
me to demonstrate that the class Q route
was an available option in order to
establish the fullback position
the planning of the states in her report
that a full assessment of the fallback
position has not been possible and
specifically refers to highways as a
console t
highways have no objection to the
conversion under a full application and
no possible reason exists as to why a
different response would be forthcoming
from a class Q application
in summary this application seeks to
remove a very considerable modern
utilitarian steel frame Barn from the
Green Belt this application also seeks
to secure the restoration of an
attractive traditional brick built Barn
into a dwelling and this can likely be
achieved by way of an amended
application but it is however
regrettable that design issues were only
raised at the committee stage rather
than during the eight-week consideration
period
I would suggest that this application
can be permitted on the following basis
30 seconds on number one the principle
of this Bond conversion is established
by gdpo class Q which provides a
material consideration and a fallback
position
the applicant has sought to engage
proactively with the planning officer
and other stakeholders by submitting a
full application and certain design
alterations would have been possible if
these have been raised as a if the
issues have been raised in a timely
manner secondly the removed with a large
steel Barn provides an enhancement to
the green belt
thirdly and lastly the submitted design
does consider relevant policies and I
would draw members attention to page 99
of the SPD which includes a photograph
of what is described as a well-designed
barn conversion I'm going to have to ask
you to wrap up the photograph shows a
bond very similar to the application
building and the the example photo
includes a bond that has had its main
doors removed in filled with glazing and
with roof lights at Eve's level thank
you marginally over sorry I think we'll
allow us okay we'll allow it on this
occasion okay members do we have any
questions for our agent please councilor
Harvey
um
he's one of the points you made was that
the uh one of the things in favoritism
applications is the removal of a modern
Barn from the Green Belt did I not hear
in the speech that you read out that the
intention was to relocate that same Barn
Elsewhere on the side you're correct the
barn has already been established so
there is already planning for the second
bomb which could be built but it will be
in the green belt after the high point
yeah that was the point you were making
yes so at the moment there is planning
for two steel bonds within your the
green belts in the green belt so in a
sense your your point was you've
undermined your point on on the Green
Belt issue councilor Harvey I I I'm not
sure we should be debating with the
applicant you've asked him a question
and I think it'll be quite polite there
are two steel barns permitted in the
green belt and under this proposal they
would only be one
thank you
um someone else did indicate and I've
forgot about sorry cancer Curtis it was
mine was the same point as counselor
we might clear that up as part of points
of clarification
um unless there are any others councilor
Adam
um just to understand it this is a
operational farm and
how much of the the operations take
place on and around the site that that
this is relating to this is primarily a
sheep farm there's very limited activity
within these barns the client uses it
primarily to house his collection of
vintage tractors
okay any further
your contribution and your patients this
evening okay we have points of
clarification too often we have no
further speaker so points of
clarification to officers I think
councilor Harvey might have a
clarification would you like me to sum
it up for you
I'll do that
I'll do that um so uh we heard as part
of the parish council submission that um
uh and it has been confirmed by the
applicants agent uh that permission has
been granted under
1903-077 agnot for a steel bomb
um that could be built out at any time
presumably uh regardless of whether this
permission is granted or refused and the
steel bond that has been proposed to be
removed as part of this application
could remain therefore having two steel
barns if this doesn't get approved
tonight and that is conditioned to be
removed is that correct
should the applicant choose to implement
the
2019 agricultural notification for the
barn yes that's in a different location
in the site but they could Implement
that as well
um I would just clarify they couldn't
take down this existing barn and
relocate it it's a separate design and
sighting Etc but so in short we could
find ourselves with two steel barns and
without this conversion yes I would I
would clarify agricultural development
is a PR is not inappropriate development
in the green belt and the loss of an
agricultural building is sort of neutral
to Greenbelt openness in that regardless
raised us on page 50 in my report thank
you very much Council Javier hopefully
that clarifies your point councilor
Jennings please
would we have more control on on this
application conditions wise rather than
if they were to go through a class queue
approach
sorry could you repeat the question
would we have more control on conditions
design Etc
um
if we're going rather than a class Q
route for instance if we if they they
said right okay we'll just go class Q
would they have would would we be able
to control
more aspects of the design
is that working as it staged on page 47
of my um my report at
design is and design and external
appearance are one of the prior approval
criteria for a class queue so
the class key applications can be
subject to design negotiations like a
full application
um that'll be more responsive if Emily
has nothing to add
so subject both types of application can
be subject to design amendments and
relevant conditions
Council Mills
thank you could you put a photograph of
the uh or slide up or what they're going
to look like thanks so
they're they're going those doors
they're going
if I just if I just if I just between
this slide and the
one so if you can see at the bottom
that'll be glazing yeah
if I get back into the photo and it
looks as though they're going to retain
the shape of the windows as well doesn't
it
if we go back yeah
okay thank you okay
Council Jennings again sorry could I
just see the rear yeah at the front the
photograph no the that one that's it
okay okay
anyone else with any points of
clarification before we moved his
debates let's get into Bates who'd like
to kick us off no one puts a hand up
I'll pick someone
okay Council Dixon
thank you chairman you'll be doing an
excellent job this evening
um
uh I
favor the officer's recommendation on
this one
um It's a situation whereby they've
summed it up as a situation whereby the
class queue is not uh in their opinion a
better solution to this one
um and I don't really like the amount of
glass that is proposed in this
development
um I appreciate that at the present time
um there's obviously an opportunity to
relocate whatever is stored uh in this
Barn uh be they uh old tractors old
farming Machinery or other storage
Etc into the new barn if it is actually
relocated elsewhere
um but I don't think there's any way we
can actually Ensure
that if we Grant this one and a modern
Barn which is fairly ugly looking thing
which is attached to this Barn is
actually reused elsewhere
and there's absolutely no way we can
actually enforce the uh
agnot which was agreed in 19 to be
constructed so you'd end up with a
situation where does that storage go
so I'm going to favor the officer's
recommendation
uh thank you count six and just find
clear is that a formal proposal
I'm happy to make another proposal yes
Jim thank you very much anyone else I'm
going to pick on someone else instead
cancer Adam
I
I'm broadly in support of councilor
Dixon's comments I think looking at the
fallback position was what kind of
solidified it and actually
um Castle Jennings question sort of made
me think that actually the the fallback
position of a class queue may be more
appropriate for this type of application
if that were to go through then I think
the existing legislation would apply the
appropriate controls whereas this seems
to be the case where they're trying to
do something in excess of that otherwise
they would be broadly supported
um so I think I'm happy to Second
Council Dixon
okay thanks very much anyone else
councilor Jennings
I'm probably
of a different opinion here
um
I think I'm not if it was mine I'd have
gone class q and just railroaded it
through
um I think we do have more control over
this
um rather than a class queue
it makes makes sense to me
um
I noticed the big Windows which are
visible there and on the roof are going
um
I don't find any part of the design of
this offensive in any way
so I'm probably of a different opinion
to every to other other expressions of
Interest so far
are you proposing a grant
I'll propose a grant then
thank you very much Council Curtis
thank you I think
you know the the parish council
also does support I think it is
important that we
take into account
um what local Parish council's views are
um and I know the comment here to
supporting what councilor Jones has just
said the parish council appreciates that
the applicant has made a full planning
application rather than seeking
conversion through committed or class Q
so I'm sort of um minded to Second
Council of the Jennings on this Monday 2
or r
will will perfect ah well ideal okay
anyone else want to say anything
um I would just add that um in my
opinion and it is my opinion um that uh
full application does allow us to have
more control
um purely on the basis that a class
queue is a notification of development
it is not a an application for
development and whilst there may be some
design negotiations at the end of the
day it is still a notification that
that's going to happen under permissive
development legislation under a full
application we have absolute control my
position would be to uh I would have
seconded cancer Jennings but it's been
done but I agree with cancergenics
councilor Curtis but that's my thoughts
unless anyone else wants to say anything
we have a proposal
no one wants to speak okay we have a
proposal to refuse in line with the
office recommendation and that's been
made by Council Dixon seconded by
councilor Adam could have a show of
hands for those in favor of refusal
please
three and those against
six and abstentions one
so that has failed so uh we therefore
have a proposal to Grant which is made
by Council Jennings executed by
councilor Curtis
um I believe the reasons given are great
weight has been provided to the uh
fallback position of the class queue
um is there anything else you want to
add or are you happy with that
okay it's only find this time too
acceptable
um are you comfortable that we have
provided sufficient detail as to why the
committee may go against your
recommendation
the answer I'm looking for is yes
so just so I'm clear
committee understand the the policy
as-10 and the reasons why officers have
recommended refusal of this on that
basis but you feel that because there is
an opportunity for prior approval
through class Q you want to give
significant weight or more weight to
that fall back position over the policy
and my understanding of that that's my
understanding and my position as well
yes okay thank you Joe yes I'm happy
with that okay do we need to talk about
conditions
yep more than happy to time limit is the
first condition recommended plans
materials in accordance with the plans
we've got details of conservation roof
lights uh the plane tiles and the brick
on the plans uh for hard and soft
Landscaping condition
um development to be carried out in
accordance with the batter nesting bird
survey
um a condition carried over from the
previous permission at the site for the
conversion which was mentioned earlier
which was recommended by the
environmental health officer which is
for the retained cart shed scene just
here if you can see my cursor
for this to be only used for
agricultural storage purposes except for
purposes of storage of slurry or sludge
and not for the housing rearing or a
combination of livestock that's to
protect the immunity of huge occupiers
um the roof likes to be conservation
style and flush with the roof of the
next condition the parking allowed to be
in accordance with that shown on this
site plan
um contamination and Remediation
conditions also recommended by
environmental health the climate change
checklist bins and water buds
pretty much anything else you guys want
to add
no marvelous okay we have a proposal to
grant for the reasons given could have a
show
sorry uh members could get to the
removal of PD rights
as well
yes justification and which classes as
well potentially
we do need to have clear justifications
for why we want to remove PD rights I'll
leave it to you to come up with
something if you want to or we can try
and do something over here
I'd like to try and do something over
there I thought you might yes
um
protect the and maintain the Royal
character of the buildings
happy yes you happy
would uh
our legals be happy with that
yes our legal officer is nodding at me
I've been advised to add something else
in and I think this is quite robust and
useful
um under class queue you would not have
permitted development right
so as we're giving great weight to the
class queue fallback position it makes
sense to therefore remove any PD rights
in line with the otherwise class in line
with what the fallback position is
happy yes happy you're happy everyone's
happy marvelous let's move to a vote so
the proposal is to grant for the reasons
given could have a share of hands for
those in favor of granting
foreign
and those against
three and abstentions none
therefore committee resolves to Grant
application
2201440 ful low welcome Farm in
Smithfield let's move to our final
application of the evening which is
application reference twenty two zero
zero nine nine one ful Waterside in
stratford-onaven representative officer
is once against Sarah flirty Sarah over
to you
thank you chairman this is a full
planning application for the
installation of a CCTV camera the
application site is located in the
Builder barrier boundary of Stratford
and is denoted by the Red Dot on this
plan the site is within the conservation
area area of restraint flood zone 3 and
within the setting of several listed
buildings including the gray 2
starlighted RSC which is seen here at
the bottom of the plan
this photo shows the lighting column
that the camera will be attached to
and here we see a another image of the
lighting column in The Wider Street
Scene
chairman of the development is
acceptable and principal and the
recommendation is therefore to Grant
Subject to the conditions as detailed in
page 62 of the agenda and the updates in
the update sheet thank you so thank you
very much members we've got no speakers
so anyone want any points clarified by
our officers know in that case we move
to the debate I will propose that we
Grant application 2200991 ful in line
with us recommendation councilor Kendall
seconded thank you very much anyone else
want to speak
no in that case can I have a vote The
Proposal is to Grant in line with office
recommendation show of hands please uh
that is unanimous committee therefore
resolves to Grant application 2200-991
ful water Sergeant Stratford Ivan I'm
assuming we have no urgent business no
urgent business so I will declare the
meeting close thank you very much
members members of the public and uh
officers for your time and help this
evening we'll see you next week